I'm on fire now water water water
yeah well you're the one who pulled it
out in the first place my name is
markiplier and welcome back to the
forest with Jack hey what's our
situation hey could you stop doing
intros we got a hairy [ __ ] I think what
I'm fighting them for a while we kind of
put them like to bed and now we well
okay what's our sitrep damn you kill one
two more come it's not a good situation
come so it's like the Hydra from her
yeah yeah okay yeah you remember that
cartoon that movie my favorite movies
yeah yeah that was awesome in the game
that came with it yeah the game actually
was fantastic the Super Nintendo version
was actually really good I love that too
no I played it on the computer that's
right I played the computer come to my
name come to me I'm coming to you jack
I've been misconstrued but not really
yeah as youtubers you say things and
then five seconds later you ever think
about what you said then you said I'm
coming Jack I'm coming yeah yeah yeah
that would have been weird so people
understand you guys are cool yeah
YouTube commenters is the most mature
yeah good yeah okay all right okay okay
so this is like back Souls I need to get
back to my body to find all myself
wait what souls for like one episode
never got mad cuz I was bad at it yeah I
could I was laying with Wade so I blame
Wade for being awful yeah it's not one
of those games you just jump into
unknown
see I super intelligent I have lots of
experience with diet demos to excellence
axles to learn to say words properly
like a proper English man yeah I need to
get back to my body you see the skull
and crossbones no I do not you do though
so let's go that's a skull it's so weird
like some ambience noises are super loud
yeah why
thank you stupid Birds I'm gonna turn it
down all the way because it's just a
nightmare
insulting my ears people always think
birds chirping is like the nicest sound
or it's not that's not a bird that's
crickets oh it is treehouse just a cabin
fever when we need to get back to all
our logs well oh yeah I need to really
lay down some thick logs so that we can
slam our logs together to build that's
right I'm sorry
it's just it's hard to make honey
windows like it really is I really want
to make them it's hard is it yeah it's
so hard it's not that hard
oh hey buddies I'm glad you guys are
still here because when I died I said oh
I hope those guys are still around my
dead body you don't remember you saying
that at all Jack I was actually
recording everything I'll go back to the
exact thing you said right after you
died that was that was what you said see
I think it was I think exactly those
words okay back of my body and then I
said you died those were my exact words
weird you ever have that you ever have
that moment where you stand over your
own dead body
yeah me too I don't see a dead body just
collected all myself see here we get on
the ground it's fine I'm down to clown
now oh so you got your phone out so what
are you doing there I'm texting also
their teeth everywhere because you beat
them out of the natives when I exploded
their bodies their teeth just went in
all directions okay so should we build a
tree house there's that mainly cool
eating tree up there what is yeah I see
what you're saying yes you see that
cubby keep trying man bad lyrics he's
okay see go go please hey we need to
build a tree house okay so I set up do
you want bunt do you want a treehouse or
an Alpine treehouse
what's an Alpine treehouse it's bigger
it's a triangular one but it needs more
logs how many logs 59 that's a lot of
logs okay yeah it doesn't go on these
trees what tree does it go on I don't
know I'm gonna win on every tree these
are these you I want this before I there
we go oh wait maybe hold on just hold on
a tick no it doesn't work on battery
that trees broken take it back it was
better that's not much better oh did we
decide you were the leader at the
beginning of this series we need to like
rewind back to that second where you
said that I said it I'll show it right
now I'll say here we go you're just
gonna edit in you saying it all cams cut
I don't trust you
like those Obama sings wait the whisper
some yeah did someone remix Obama to say
that no but I hope they do now I don't
think he's ever said Oh
words at once but yeah I don't think
Obama has ever said well you could hear
him say Obama and change it into mama
did you guys fight each other
maybe a little why would they fight each
other because sometimes they do there's
like different natives some of them are
more naked than others yeah there's like
pale ones they're looking at me funny
yeah we're not dudas like all up in my
grill yeah all up in my face area they
trippin on all up in my business yo I
don't I don't yeah all up in my face
Bowl you gotta use guys been hitting the
shrooms
in this forest I've never had a shroom
is there shrooms in this forest yeah
sometimes the poison you okay but what
about the other times other times that
make you trip balls
whoo I like those times can we make
those times happen what you've already
had those times when you don't see the
water okay have you ever played unturned
yeah yeah I played that on livestream
that was actually really fun of playing
with Bob and Wade and we did everything
we needed to do like everything was
actually accomplished there every single
thing you can do in that game you can do
it like two episodes well which is
exactly what I did I did like a video of
it and then I did another video on it or
Mikey
I seen the whole map that's true I mean
if you're not playing with other people
that are trying to ruin your day at all
turns it's really gonna be kind of slow
yeah it has potential
no no kidding for being made by like a
16 year old kid in his baby yeah it's
really impressive
he's much better than I am yeah well I
mean it's what I always emphasize in
games like the gameplay has to be first
and foremost the graphics can come later
but so long as the game is fun you know
it can be the prettiest game in the
world but if it ain't fun it's not worth
it yeah Crysis 3 yo I didn't play crazy
I played Chris I haven't two races one
is oh good just perfect there's one of
those games you just you got a plate is
that your Italian accent yeah say your
yamimash ax
it's Irish and Italian at the same time
in America it came out as space Broncos
again it's gonna be wrong cause you've
never seen hi I saw it after that
episode a good use of your time might I
say right yes the Yukio Ana's liquid - I
have not seen you good there are like a
dozen of these guys yeah they're not
necessarily attacking we got a bit of an
alfresco situation going on and I'm
running like 20 frames per second
pigeons not good why are you doing that
I didn't choose to god there's so many
thing we need to say like build this
treehouse as quick as we can how are
they not killing us I can't stay at one
tree long enough so I'm just gonna help
you out with this one yeah smack them
don't educate them don't poke the bear
where'd it go
we're weird the logs the tree is gonna
poop a little hurt like all of my blood
is not gone but some of it is out of my
body okay we're almost there we only
need seven more logs seven more just
quit your bellyachin oh now my frame
rates are dropping what did you do there
oh oh oh oh that's you fire I don't know
some [ __ ] ways that are you on four
wait I can't see these girls so I don't
know hey you know here my god yeah but I
don't know if that's on fire you might
just be lying for attention I mean hey I
wouldn't put hey that's what I do I like
that I know I'm a habitual liar
he was almost already cut convenient Oh
again didn't mean to well it sounds like
you did because you've died twice and
I've died none oh maybe because I make
the distraction oh because you're the
poop attraction because how about maybe
just shush how about you don't die okay
yeah that's that's a good plan yeah I
agree with that one yeah okay yeah okay
break okay I can't sprint back to you I
have no health I I could eat the rocky
raccoon
come here raccoon raccoons are full of
nutrition right we eat them straight
wrong I don't think you can can you know
I just beat open a suitcase with a stick
well if that's not manly nothing is it's
pretty manly but not as manly as what I
did I beat it open with my face there's
a fine line between manly and stupidity
right on that border trees but every
time I go around to find a tree they
like swarm me why didn't they suddenly
like appear out of every hair cuz we
were shouting and we went back to the
same place where they were oh it's a we
know when it's when it's I'm the leader
it's just you but no series make your
camp by the plane by the plane stop it
okay we're in this mess we might as well
just do with what we have hey I just
need a few more logs for the tree houses
there will climb up we'll yell at them
for get off our lawns before more you
know for my loan damn kind of is that
you heard damsel in distress voice
damsel in distress knows my old man
voice damsel it started off as a damsel
no chance I got one log I'm a-comin okay
you get that log we just need two more
after that
where's the tree house oh it's over here
yeah that's where you put it you with a
giant yellow hammer symbol is did you
play this game oh okay I'm climbin what
in the world you were just like stock
arms to your side flow to the tree house
so this is fun we did it chippy did your
degree taste as if we chop down this
tree yeah you can chop down the tree
through this thing I'll stay here really
hey attention please there is an air
strike inbound if you want to survive
get lost what does that mean for us
wouldn't that kill us too boss tree
house of steel we put this city
we've been up this city a lot we built
the city on your multiple dead bodies
just just didn't mean didn't mean to
ruin your flow sir
carry on too soon sorry okay okay my
head has this finger starting to get
bird yeah there's the bird hello let off
my fingers I got a bit of a situation I
think you're just telling me to smell
your fingers
their treehouse so thank you all so much
for watching thank you jack for taking
all the death so that I didn't look bad
yeah we'll try something else new okay
it dawned on me that I forgot my outro
yeah you all - tongue for - thank you
jack
thank you jack have a good one I trust
you completely
[Music]